ثالث كايوشي دبي رونالدو
لاول مره في ملاعب كره القدم وما قصه علكه
انجلترا هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على
العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
افضل شعور مع الافضل في العالم بهذه
الكلمات عبر لاعب النصر تالسيكا عن فرحته
بالهدف الذي سجله في مرمى الاتفاق امس في
مباراه عرفه الظهور الاول لكريستيانو
رونالدو مع فريقه الجديد المصري وكانت
لسكس احتفل بالهدف رفقه رونالدو في الملعب
وعلى انستغرام يسجل النجم البرتغالي
اعجابه بالصوره
سلاح جديد اصبح بحوزه حكام كره القدم اكثر
لطفا واقل جدلا البطاقه البيضاء التي ظهرت
لاول مره في قمه الدوري البرتغالي للسيدات
وتم تقديم البطاقه للطاقم الطبي في مباراه
الذي تعاون لمعالجه لاعبه وتم تصميم
البطاقه البيضاء لاظهار تقدير الانديه
للاعب النظيف اثناء المباراه في محاوله
لتحسين القيم الاخلاقيه في الرياضه
في مشهد طريف وغير متوقع طلب مشجع المغربي
من مدرب ريال مدريد
ليس الصوره او توقيع بل علكه الطريف في
الامر ان انجيلاتي تعامل مع الموضوع
بطريقه عاديه ليقوم المدرب الايطالي
بمدغه للعلكه تخفيفا للتوتر كبديل للسجائر
على حد تعبيره
[موسيقى]
مع عائلتي بهذه الكلمات وجها نجم المنتخب
المغربي ونادي باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي
اشرف حكيمي القائمين على جائزه في الرياض
والتي حصل عليها بصفته الرياضيه الافضل
خلال العام كما نشر حساب نادي باريس سان
جيرمان صوره لحكيم اليوم مع والدته رفقه
الجائزه معلقه كيف تصف روعه الصوره
[موسيقى]